[Musique]
en 1972 quatre jeunes photographes
s'installent à d'israëlie dans la région
de chaudière à palaches pour
photographier durant trois mois des gens
ordinaires on choisit des huiler parce
qu'on voulait une place qui était pas
urbaine pas trop grand qui était pas
mourant comme beaucoup de petites places
au Québec je pouvais être une bonne
grosse action de la société québécoise
[Musique]
il capte son phare mais avec
authenticité la réalité des villageois
sans le savoir ils écrivent au chapitre
marquants de l'histoire de la
photographie au Québec on l’invente la
photographie on invente de mon point de
vue on invente la photographie
contemporaine au Canada on se promenait
c'était vraiment un sabre d'échanger
avec les gens qu'on leur demandait s'ils
acceptaient d'être photographié les gens
quelquefois
dans ton état de tous les jours après la
publication des photos la polémique
éclate les notables locaux peu habituer
à des photos aussi réalistes sending de
l'image qu'elle renvoie du village dans
la presse deux visions s'affrontent
doit-on représenter le réel ou renvoyer
une image sublimée c'était une époque
identitaire forte au Québec c'est le
début des années 70 donc c'était un
petit peu représenté ça on est tout le
monde est important ça vaut la peine de
photographier le monde négligeant ce
documentent leur quotidien
l'exposition d'israélie revisitée
présente 144 photographies dont 67
inédites de même que des enregistrements
audio captés à l'époque
ces enregistrements audio là ont été
comme perdus pendant 50 ans et puis ont
été retrouvés dans la préparation de
l'exposition 50 ans plus tard on salue
la pertinence de ce travail de
documentaire précieux et les questions
éthiques cruciales qui le soulevaient
forcément déjà au départ il y a une
qualité photographique indéniable d'une
part et la polémique est venu donner
quelque chose de supplément d'armes et
un immense supplément d'âme
au pourquoi de la photographie comment
nous photographions pour qui nous
photographions d'Israël et revisité et à
l'affiche du Musée McCord jusqu'au 19
février il signait bien Alexandre
Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal